[Music]
[Music]
yeah hello and welcome to this video yet
another blitz session with me consuming
big mark of team
I changed the layout a little bit
calling to a suggestion made in a video
from yesterday or the day before and I
think is indeed for the better so I'm
going to create a game so we see how the
difference is ok let's go 3 & 2
no not for 3 + 2 and give it a roll I
hope it looks fine it should be a good
view during the game and also a better
analysis view without me switching
around different scenes here in OBS so
I'd be a little bit
now the sound um so I think this is
better I actually had intended something
else for today I did not want to do a
live blood session but something let's
say a little bit more sophisticated
however this did not quite work out I
will do it probably tomorrow I hope
quite a bit of them
uncomfortable night I somehow yeah for I
fell asleep during watching a video and
I had such an unlucky position it seems
that now my neck is like stiff I cannot
really move my neck and it's been a bit
painful so I don't want to do anything
that is too sophisticated and I don't
get a game here this is crazy
so maybe I have to go 5-0
people don't want increments it's really
a shame I don't get it
guys learn to play chess playing Cremant
seems tough
maybe I just go for this and lift
this is reasonable let's play so I think
the board should be fine it's the same
size and you get all the relevant
wattage great
you get all the relevant information I
guess that you need
like the time and directing x' it's a
little bit obstructed
after after inches in
this is better right so and now let's
play people are playing fat cool see us
calm do not name
is that okay yeah you see everything
that you need to see both players
ratings and what did I recommend against
that I think if I write both players
ratings and the time and ultimately you
will also see them analysis in good view
yeah why displaying a completely non
theoretical setup in that is very
unambitious but of course it's difficult
to just wipe white out you know it's
like the whole centers blocked them Ont
in my favor is that I have the
opportunity to play f5 this is much
easier to do than whites to be play a
form
95y he was probably angling for Bishop
g5 after 97 that wouldn't have been
terrible but it's completely okay to
prevent us and aged h6 is kind of useful
anyway in the long run so castle
yeah this looks nice but ultimately
after f5 white has to answer the
question
what about a four now and then the Queen
and Bishop are not all that well placed
this already looks a little bit awkward
for white
some course happily taking this now
White's pawn structure is basically
destroyed
I just need to pick up the porn now
essentially I don't see how he will ever
keep it
if I've I mean the pawn is d5 now a
simple way here should be Queen to b6
queen maybe then quincy form so go let's
go be six we should be seven that is a
way to do this
you cannot play 92 intending Bishop f3
because f4 would trap the bishop which
he allows that's a really odd game
okay now I'm a piece up right
it's need to complete my development
and make sure that he doesn't have
anything good against my king
yeah Bishop to g4 is probably his idea
which is understandable um yeah I can
probably just
enact rooks and then prepare to trade on
the F file
you
yes I'll have to be
to be alert my main issue one of the
main issues that I have been shares and
said I'd lose interest in games when
they also like I'm a piece up and the
game is essentially over there is no
real challenge anymore and then I just
don't pay attention and this is costing
me a lot of points really a lot of
points so I said I have to somehow
convince myself to look at this game and
this is some not so easy sometimes
I am giving up b5 but
important
I want to get my bishop into the pill
into the game Bishop g5 III this would
be fantastic
another bishop should
help attacking White's King actually
I'd next this covers d6 and keeps it
covered our threat now is Queenie r4
which would leads to a maid and some
moves which he cannot defend against
really
where's the maid
check
mate yeah that was a fairly
straightforward game okay I'm going to
give him a rematch
star you can
do a better job with black so we have
four nights scotch
is 6cm okay against the six you have a
couple of good options I recommend we
should be five in my book
this is some usually very nice for white
when you're three if I remember
correctly allowing night at five
yeah even e5 is a pretty good choice I
think I'm going for that
there should be a pretty favorable
transformation he has to take the night
now not sure what he's thinking about
what
okay
I know I'm sorry
some other games okay so let's go for a
new opponent
you know it was a bit odd when he had a
2200 rating there
or thought so let's go for another efore
game or change and I should actually
drink the tea
yeah I hope I'm going to make this video
that I was talking about oops
slow him tomorrow
it's going to be a hope interesting
the subject is going to be
is it our older chess books useful for
chess improvement in the modern
the modern era like today is it useful
to use them let's say seventy years over
talk or sixty or book um I'm but I'm I
were using a famous famous older book
for an example
so make sure to
stay tuned let's say on my channel
okay so we have a one of the main lines
here of the scourge for Knights
line that I'm advocates in Miami keep it
simple efore book some things is a very
reasonable way to play for white it's
extremely safe you don't have a bad
piece and you generally speaking have to
play really really odd rules we ever get
in trouble which is I think something
that is it's undervalued as a virtue in
Chelsea and there's a kind of the
sturdiness opposition what what do you
have to do to really be in bad shape
probably after the speak speech I'm
going to do something silly and lose
quickly ads it can of course happen
absolutely but I hope this is not going
to be the case all right now many things
are possible here you can
take on the six warm flame 92 I think
I'm going to take
an interesting question yam is if rook
f4 is something that needs to be
prevented not completely certain I'm
going to play 92
the night in the long run very often
goes for this journey anyway and the
move see form is something that I
definitely would like to play this is
one of the key ideas in this in this
line after C form we quite often see a
favorable constructor transformation
after taking or emptying on d5 all right
so he goes with this um yeah
can whatsapp lame
and also just play a three year and sent
him back problem
why is he doing something funky IQ gauge
for I cannot quite believe that no root
edge for I have Queen g3 this is
probably not a good idea
okay now queen g3 is an interesting
possibility that leads to him
Ali well-known endgame which should be
about equal I just wonder if I have
something else here available he has put
the corn on a5 so attacking this pawn
somehow might also be might also be
feasible
a for I've got before ok I'm going to
apply rook t1 first which makes it a
little bit more
difficult for black play c5 as then the
rook here against them win
it's going to be annoying
you
came
cannot mean I can play see for ib3 is
tactically covered you to Bishop age
seven word is so not start a good move
firm anyway
I'm going to uniform
or for the [ __ ] trade
you
yeah I wonder if he wants to play the
more c5 here okay
[Music]
okay
and expect this movement seems like what
is what does he want to do
go rookie one they cannot move the night
I'm threatening f3 and
oh I'm really not sure about this I'd
say Bishop d7 if it's an idea for me to
just take
and to change the pawn structure in that
way
yeah I think I'm going to do it there's
this currently as slight as a slight
this some disharmony in blacks position
based on the on the bishop here let's
see so I think I'm taking this and go
what you won and now where do you go
like doesn't really have a good spot for
the bishop yeah
and this might be enough to get at least
I'm a small advantage should f5 I go g4b
should be six I take
and yeah book g8 now so you have to play
something that you are not so happy
about
does this look really odd
now how do we how do we go here about
this I can go G for is connecting
yeah
hmm 92 c3 is also quite
so it looks quite promising
you
so 93 years f5
94 King 7 just about her world
let's go here and then 93
it's not so easy for me to keep this 93
you
No
again winning the pawn
don't see how is keeping it so I think
I'll take with the pawn I mean II form
will remain weak
you
I could have taken with the noid we
should checks and then the trade maybe
that was a that was an even simpler
solution now that I think of it
you
mm yeah that was that was quite a bit
simpler
I mean here I'm better I am a pawn up
but the other other one was probably
more convincing okay I have to check the
time a little bit this is 5-0 I don't
get an increment and the scan
really
be a problem
not really aware of the of the non
increment Oh to same and then all of a
sudden I'm losing on time
[Music]
and that is editors another poll right
or does he cover that I don't see
yeah and now he's taking too long
like to somehow he's called food Fox
outfox me in the time scramble that's
not going to work now
giving me the spawn and he still cannot
this one
okay some to just have a view at the
analysis I think this is good right so
we have a we have the move list
and we also have the analysis on top so
you can see I think what I'm what I'm
checking so here I think we had a
roughly echo position this should be
about equal the engines has 0.2 yeah
again roughly equal this position now it
drops down to zero but 94 I wasn't so
sure about rookie one is a little bit
annoying and here probably 96 stronger
you know 96 and then we play this
position which again is probably about
equal but here we we get into something
that is as I said pretty annoying
because the bishop here is attacked and
it has no natural wave on no natural
square to go to is just a slight
disharmony at the moment rupee seven is
probably better than what the ATM I
believe that
mm yeah root deform a5 something like
that is better for white like edge form
it's just he has the worst pawn
structure it's three islands against two
so Luke 2:8 and it seems g4 was more
precise than 92 where he should play a 5
then I did now f5 is a bit better
[Music]
in a defense now now this is not
possible anymore and I'm winning
material
yeah I wonder actually what about this
we have done that sometimes tricky at
first you think this must be again super
easy win but maybe this is not the case
yeah at the end I should get doubts I'd
pass on with B form
yeah but the engine is giving us
probably riots like this I'd say this
could this thing here should win
and I will get get a peso him that
should win yeah but she takes also very
strong I just I just get the e4 pawn and
I'm playing this ending comfortably for
win okay so let's go for a new game
maybe I can get a three plus two to
prefer that
I get one spicy laowhy
interesting names
okay
the London
you
we take such okay
okay I can play many things here maybe
just night eight six Oh No
when a five certainly also works
you
Joe
wonderous is he does he have something
really concrete now that is
every somewhat irritating like efore
maybe before if I check on if or no
there sometimes is a tactic like efore
Knight takes bishop a6b takes Queen d5
double attack on the night and requite I
have created five check after Bishop a6
had this I couldn't couldn't quite
and quite believe that it leads to
anything
[Music]
okay
this flavor that's for sure
you
as usual them
the positions in them
the London a super solid
hey I can go six the night on a six is
art of course
I think
taking this on a six assists of any
concern
maybe okay it's not possible anymore
I wanted to say maybe night a3 b5 could
be something
you
it's probably just about equal
I know he does take okay
Jim I wouldn't have done that much over
bishop bishop
should have fan a team
yeah of course he has weakened he has
weakened to the structure a bit of it
that's what it is
on a big deal
you
in now how do we play us is interesting
I can play with d6
sixty-five
d 5 I'm going for the D 6 D 6 setup
okay
don't necessarily want to trade even
more
[Music]
I know it is okay for me
you
now should be six
d6
not really be attacked anymore
Bishop 1 g3 is offside
you
okay
square six
yeah this is now very very good for
black
I don't see him
and I don't know how he's going to
handle all those here voice weak now
these six cannot be attacked is the
thing just cannot attack this
an interesting moment here would be if I
can go away five I don't know if I can
I can also play rooks you form this is
good in many ways
also as a little trap here maybe he goes
through kitchen then should age five
could be a thing
yeah I think well
many things are good really
six
[Music]
you
okay Celeste
I don't mind that rupee 85
but both captures are strong which I'll
take with this
now what what can happen here said I
ultimately get the full center like
after some f5 and then takes and d5 at
the end yeah that can easily happen
okay now the thing is that rook b5 is so
annoying the night has knows good square
Norwood square to go tomb I'm also
threatening rook takes his recently
winning a pawn
white is under quite some pressure here
now rook b5 simply oil take on c3 ever
take on c3 as Bishop takes a 7 it's not
a bad trade of the slaver Mimi
I think I'm going to
snatch the porn
okay I just I just saw Bishop a7
and here I can take H we are to win an
exchange
okay now how do we win this rookie 496
yeah why not
it was one hope to just end the game
immediately hmm yet the ending was just
very good very good for me same
Oh
you
so we transpose to a Catalan
Katalin absolutely mainline
you
now here the best move for black is p5
but that is not an easy move to make
if you don't know this inside out
d5 pawn takes Bishop d7 ISM pawn
sacrifice
okay this is possible I think
just one day I'm okay 95 he's going to
play he's probably going to play book is
7
okay I'm just I'm just keepin it simple
just stay stay true to the motto and
not to anything too fancy
maybe you can one
if I played before here he takes it
night xb6
isn't that a bit awkward
I'm just I'm going through this let's
see
not
to optimistic the abbot's looks like it
should work a more or less has to take
it right he has no other square to go to
we should before can be considered but
don't know if this is really a
significant thing so I'm going to take
b6
to
also to a seven trying a sir
yeah it works you get it editor William
now I was thinking Bishop III here but
94 could be an annoyance
Oh
Meah
it's a [ __ ] it's a bit
it off-putting
[Music]
you have 95 then now you have 95 I
Bishop can take ok so that doesn't
doesn't work at all
here's Bishop c5 though
yeah it doesn't lead to anything is
really it's really not that fantastic
okay so what are we going to play not I
don't like it
[Music]
I cannot immediately exploit this
situation it's pretty much nothing I
mean even if if at all we'd be less than
nothing
but we could be pushed back with all the
pieces this is kind of a non move
Aaron Bishop III
yes Bishop here is pretty much pretty
much annoying on before
yeah let's see what happens not not
completely certain it takes usually some
stupid moves to be worse with white in
Indus and this kind of line I'm not sure
if I managed this already
we worse
okay week about this
not really threatening anything won't be
forward maybe you will still take it
okay so now
Norma one to capture
let's not take ages
maytag's okay
[Music]
yeah it's all it's a little bit loose
yeah my the night on v6 was loose
should probably have should have gone
back problem was a bit too quickly
played
not threatening to take on d5 is the
problem because after he takes night
moves my 95 is dropping
this actually varies very stupidly
played
I must had to play 91
I D for something like that but II five
was really stupid square now something
like rook c8 is immensely immensely
difficult to answer
you can take 96 but this is just going
nowhere
and they have no good square for the
queen with a stupidly played game
very very bad
yeah after the move I just have no good
move here
ah yeah and I managed to lose the game
in this line this is actually really
difficult
it's such a save line
the heritage of play 95 that was just
extremely extremely bad
now rupee aid is just just winning
we need 392 something like that will win
you
[Music]
into it
with shocking
my Derby might still be lost the night
on v6 just has nowhere to go
you
hmm and now it's not lost
you
nice try not to lose
black
wait wait wait wait the night is saying
yeah I'm really unhappy with this
never get into any trouble in this line
like something like this is just like
comfortably slightly better always and
shouldn't really happen okay Knight g5
is stronger here 95 okay 794
yeah this is stronger this no nightie
form
don't even care about the pawn and use
the odd position here
you know okay some probably I need to
improve somewhere here we should be true
is better
I didn't didn't quite find something
good here should be too seems to be
better
this was like cream III I thought for it
for ages there and couldn't find
anything that I liked and this is yeah
I'm just just nothing ship take seems to
be a huge mistake it takes
he takes
yeah now the engine evil is dropping at
least it's not terrible for me it's it's
not good yeah of course
but I want to emphasize how bad 95 was
if I if I just plain i t1 or 94 or
something like that let's say 94 which
is sometimes going here I don't have a
problem at all I can just take the 5
next and it's fine and night fe 5 it's
just terrible
after a look on the C file you really
have to so rook t4 is keeping it okay
and E 4 before
I didn't see form
why can he not just take the deal then
96 okay now I didn't see that and then
it sends still okay for me I didn't see
this I just took here out of panic
because I didn't see what to do and now
why isn't Ruby a twinning
and probably everything wins but
just thought you piayed into the double
attack I couldn't really see what's
going on then
yeah it's winning yeah recreate still
lost
I guess my night Celeste no squares but
he found a way to yeah I have nothing
but here it's kind of owning a part for
black a little bit you maybe does don't
necessarily have to do with yeah but the
trend is obviously not in whites um in
in blacks favor okay so let's see if we
can get another game this is not going
to be so long it's really a bit painful
even to just keep the head focused on
the screen I'm sorry
or the six yeah I can switch to an e for
opening here
[Music]
yeah in my book I have no idea three
keeping it simple you know but this is
also interesting not so simple though
you
pancham
get this huge pawn on roller going
like is playing many poor moose but I'm
also not despair not innocent in this
regard also played six born was
okay wants to go u5m
[Music]
you
before I go to etool
my center still should be
protected enough
you
no story black-black seems to be okay
this one Wow
wouldn't wouldn't have crossed my mind
in a million years probably
so g5 and now what each form
okay so I take f66 g3 I don't have
anything there
hmm
you
very difficult
let's add tick tick g3 a teacher salmon
Bishop takes you seven
really strange
and it would be absolutely excellent for
me I wouldn't have played a four because
then I could cancel quickly to the
queenside
maybe I can still do that but it is not
as clear-cut in my mind
but let's say a tick here right I take a
five and I go Queen to g4 and then I'm
castling queenside isn't as good
yeah it's too good
would be even better if I wouldn't have
a foreign but when I got it I have it
played really here so it's just just how
it is that same
and don't quite see what he's doing them
there are some funky tactics though all
the same
so I thought Bishop f6 may be here
castles
when castles queenside and then I saw
something like Google H for Queen g3
takes a for Bishop takes rook takes
Queen takes 55
that's giving away the queen it's not
forced at all I can check on Jade
so now I think just castling queenside
yeah that should be
right or do we have something else
something that's better
[Music]
I'm going to cast
the situation here with the Queen and
this should be should be something
No
I think he also wants to cancel
take the bone
maybe Bishop f3 to g4
and maybe I should go f5x believe this
is something that I should consider
it's it's a tough call if he takes on f4
he gets the e5 square this is what I was
a little bit afraid of just just now
but it's tough to say really if f5 is
right here what if I should do something
else
now if he takes actually Bishop takes c3
my King is completely completely
[Music]
that was a bad idea I guess
not sure if this is the reason though
I thought maybe taking was good and then
taking on c3
should age form I feel this is wrong
[Music]
that seems wrong
you
okay how do we do this now I can take a
five here
[Music]
I mean I can actually take why not
he takes 95 is pretty terrible
now okay he's got but before here
push it away first
Bishop a7 is actually interesting next
with the Queen
you
Queen b6 maybe
or queen a5
extremely dangerous
you
now that
bit of an odd game didn't quite didn't
quite understand what was going on so
maybe have a quick look at the analysis
I was really shocked about h5 that
didn't move it completely did not have
on the agenda
oh and a computer things that doesn't
work okay
it wants to go night at 5:00 p.m. but
okay my choice is not disliked by the
engine and I'm kind of okay with this
this is this feels okay Bishop f6 castle
screen side
we need seven so the engine is kind of
it's okay with what I did I took it
castles and even Bishop f3 is a decent
move so maybe I didn't actually do
anything wrong it just felt very
difficult very very unconventional you
should age for looked wrong I was more
afraid of the capture Bishop takes and
then I thought maybe he can take here
but this is probably not such a big deal
[Music]
ya mean the check
looks very scary but he only has the
Queen and at the end of the day this is
probably going to be a problem him his
his King is very weak because we doesn't
class for I mean this is crazy
really a bit crazy yeah Bishop g4 is
also coming the bishops are super strong
yeah that was not intended I missed the
whole idea entirely but so here F takes
e5 was better
but I didn't really do anything wrong so
that turned out to be reasonably well
played from my end but yeah I felt
during the game like I have no clue
what's going on so like one more game
and then I'm probably going to go to bed
or something yeah let's go three plus
two again
and brutal six okay Muhtar okay
so we got them um what is this called
Englund gambit right
you
yeah you shouldn't go bishop c3 then
cross that again Bishop XIII
there was this trick
super-sweet c3
for Queen d2 takes on subsequent
experience e1 made okay yeah I just
wanted to recall what what the idea was
Wow
have a bit of a hard time to believe
this
okay so let's say ninety form
maybe it's just drunk
thing like that
okay so how do we win now would be one
Queen a three
it's already closed
you
my divorce unprotect
so
[Music]
if I go eight three first maybe and push
him back
I think I should have a win I should
just win and not just be better
[Music]
quite edit to work
you
ya know I have to play something I
cannot take take even longer
[Music]
now say look here
and a three
you
so
move the night now I don't think this
leads to much
you
[Music]
between a piece
you
yeah maybe 92 or something but I mean
the big issue with the angular gambatesa
like most the queen like a million times
it's just
ultimately based on one movers so take
this yeah I was thinking for a moment
because rookie three years in this
position and
[Music]
yeah registers developer
me something
more active let's aim to end the game
right away
it refers to right Jim
price that somebody who's flying the
Anglin gambit is going for an increment
game
because one of the few ideas of the
opening is to retain wide and maybe I
get some some some clock advantage
the longer the time control the more
ridiculous the opening is actually
yeah the queen is not really having May
squares
Knight f4 and Knight c3 are pretty
annoying
okay this is an easy easy game to play
you just have um you have my turret up
and order all the pieces are well
positioned
so queen g6 and then yeah I can just
take on d5 and the queen is trapped
no squares
the six and then 85 and the Queen has
absolutely nowhere to go - yep
give him one rematch it's fair to do and
then I'm losing the session
odd combination the Anglin gambit and
the London
you can play the London system of course
in a more active wavered
not like it's totally boring or anything
but still
he finally covers the pond maybe I could
have taken it but
not sure
I'm just going form
development and
that the white piece placement is not so
effective
it's of course completely fine for white
but if you just imagine my position
essentially looks like Sicilian and he
has some some odd pieces and now we kind
of
more sicilian ish position
so feel very comfortable here
the best dragons you can imagine
is that where the Ben's name is coming
from imagine dragons
yeah every single chest possession
position you would think about our
imagine this would be a dragon I don't
think this is the the reasoning behind
the name
it's very tempting to sacrifice on c3
very tempting
the only reason why this is probably not
so great is that
b6 is hanging I still want to do it and
if I can't help myself
now Knight takes e4 seven
not so good
yeah my idea was that the simple move
should give me compensation just
strategically I would win one of the
pants miscue me for why do you give me a
form I thought it was the pawn that
should be covered
okay
very surprised that you
to give me this pawn
now ya night see five instead of move or
is that stupid trying to gain a three
okay this rook c8 can't be bad
increase the pressure
I came did not really register that he
had this
it's annoying
but it's okay it's not like don't think
I'm in deep deep trouble
[Music]
and check me but okay anyway I just go
back and this aim
[Music]
my my structure is absolutely absolutely
nice and he has really lots of
weaknesses so it should be enough to
compensate I'm not sure I'm better word
I should be okay
g-form maybe as an idea and this I can
answer with is 6 of snow
or I have to go Aoife which I don't
really want to play
you
is six context districts it's still
pretty good
oh gee for Quinn takes discipline
and I would need a good move with the
rook but I don't have a good
I have this Quincy five check but then
Queen D four is working
really like to place
okay Doosan time
you
I expect him to take on the seven you
should really take this opportunity if I
get to take on g4 and kilo of his pawn
structure completely that cannot be
right
yeah
you
I've maybe a move
another threatening 95 so yes to here so
take this seven now
allowing my night to e5 looks pretty
strange
well let's meet it like pre-move f7 is
kind of tender but I want to go Knight
e5 next and then the knight only five
will be
exceptionally well-placed covering of
seven and is just like in the middle of
the board
if he allows Knight e5 here his bishop
will just be a completely terrible piece
because it can never attack anything oh
okay this is a really huge strategic
mistake I think unless I'm overlooking
something tactical at of course off and
parkin yep omnia but materially speaking
it was earned as a bad decision
you
you
he wants to go to f4 I guess
you
so I can always call 97 I'm concerned
gee five would be good be good to play
it doesn't work so I'm going to go for
this but now I'm threatening five
just not reacting ring
we doesn't even have a good square to go
to but we won I guess
you
I just had a look because I why is he
continuing it says some trickery huh
nothing really there
yeah just one one one or two things I
want to check the exchange sacrifice
it's kind of I mean the engine gives 94
which is not a surprise I think this is
objectively stronger I just couldn't
help myself this is just a fairly normal
dragon type of position where I should
be fine I mean I'm not getting
checkmated or anything and I have the C
file this is like pretty normal yeah I
think engine gives zero and I'm happy
with this umm and I'm certain that this
is not best I just again I couldn't help
myself to to get this this textbook kind
of situation so and here I was really
surprised that he decided to give me
four I expected she have what I expected
is actually silly I thought I gave three
or twenty fourth of course a stronger
move I didn't really see this at all
yeah man this probably means that it's
more or less refuting the whole thing if
he can keep all the power I need one
pawn I need one corn for this again I
kind of expected that this is not right
but I still wanted to do it was kind of
more matter of will then the end in
ratio so who came this should be five is
probably better
yeah yeah I'm fine I'm definitely fine
in this position
maybe an ID takes is better but yeah
here here the thing is I would love to
play his six and actually computer once
to do this as well so I saw this but I
wasn't quite sure what to do here
because I really wanted to take g4 and
kill off his structure but he can take
d7 and I couldn't really figure a move
out a queen he's got Queen d4 and it's a
check that doesn't really help and so
okay the engine wants to play this move
which is looking good actually it looks
at this
I did you know I didn't want to give him
the opportunity trade to Bishop because
the bishop can be extremely useless in
this position and this is what we've
seen a little bit later yeah when I saw
it okay yes to take um so if we so here
a group before and now not c4 is equal
[Music]
this is this
exam yeah it's kind of imaginable that I
have got a good player notice that
everything is on dark squares this is
what I meant with the bishop is kind of
not participating because the game is
completely running on dark squares so
let's see how it went so this one I have
played King g8 kind of yeah I didn't
quite know what to do I couldn't get a
six to work so I just went here and I
think you should just take
or after a five computer wants me to go
g5e here why just has to take this is
kind of clear I'm what I'm not quite
convinced
off is that white should be better here
that that I have a hard time to believe
buta insists that white has an advantage
in this position
[Music]
you
that I don't quite believe
maybe it's a it's a matter of specifics
really because just generally speaking
if I get the Knight to e5 this is such a
monster piece it covers everything I
don't quite see what he's doing then
with his rooks is the argument and I
already got a pawn but maybe the the
thing is that my queen is so awkwardly
placed him I take here this rook a form
that is not great
threatening okay four so Queen eight-six
is maybe what I have to do Queenie 495
but this is the thing then the engine
actually sees that I have problems to
keep the a7 pawn okay and this this
makes the whole evaluation more
understandable because just structurally
speaking this is always enough
compensation but in an event was a seven
it's it's a different kind of thing of
course um maybe then this is a line that
needs to be considered
yeah but I'm struggling here they're
definitely okay so this means he should
take that actually can't fight for an
advantage because he has specifically
and the the opportunity to get the a
porn if my queen let's say you imagined
we just imagined the Queen would be here
like safely then I go ninety five and I
can basically never lose it's only black
that that could be better and this is
kind of Awesome
yeah you see that route before it's a
bit small on the screen for me but look
before is the move that gives white this
advantage to 0.5 or whatever it is and
everything else is better for black and
this was my judgement I just judged the
whole or I just just the general
features of the position and I didn't
see that
rook-a for immediately and combined with
Queen e4 is actually difficult to keep
the porn um I just wondered but do this
maybe can I play this
and then look-see form and I do
understand it's not ideal I don't want
to trade rooks here I would like to keep
oh that wasn't Muslim so this is this
right if I may say this is not well
coordinated
so not easy we know anything but okay
that's interesting
he played Bishop b2 where this is this
is a strategic mistake because the
bishop will never find a good spot
or 95
okay I could've taken c3 I was more
concerned about
you are keeping everything covered let's
aim
and TM this is clearly better for me
okay I'm a head one blunder yeah engine
wants me to play g5
ready
no 95 95 by 95
it has it doesn't have many good squares
him
like here and then whatever okay it's
not a huge deal and keeping an advantage
here now okay g5 extend a pretty simple
wind yeah there are some interesting
points in this in this game for sure I
definitely should not take on c3 yet
again it was it was more out of
curiosity than anything else okay I hope
you enjoyed the video I think probably
tomorrow I'll be back with that that
video that I already told you about
earlier about all the chess books do
they make sense as a modern training
tool um hope this will work I hear my
neck has to become better really a bit
painful to sit here for a longer time
okay guys thanks for watching